Yes i you know we have a son and he
lives in lismore and it really is.
He's not really interested
in this experiment at all.
He came here when he was 16
and he was too young to see any real
benefit in it in too old to be to be my to
be formed by yes.
However my oldest daughter the first time
she visited us we were living in a tent
and she came here
and it was just a bare paddock he was
no trees there wasn't a tree from
that into this and you know
there's no trees at all
and she said she's told me years
later i wonder what are the mum
and dad going to do here you know.
However a few years after
she came to live here
and as nice with our family
a quiet time with naming
but two family houses here.
There's no reason at all if
our son ever wanted to come
and build a cabin on either of those
blocks inland. So that's good.
It's been an experience
for me it's probably been
a dumb many things in my
life in a jazz musician.
I've been a seaman lies a hole
or sorts of things you know i think
this is given me more interest
than possibly any other thing in
my life watching this developing
and helping over you know it's been
a very rewarding sort of experience
and to see the village now just expanding.
I know that building down there
is going to create activity
and i know what happens
when the pool got some.
Long as if the dream of
that expansion with.
All the right sort of
ideal stays with it then
and i'm sure it will be from
the billing truth
or it was an economic experiment not
something in the best sense it was an
experiment in people's hearts.
Everybody participated and so.
I feel i do regard this as
a major change in my life.
Elvis got an enormous benefit
of also pulled my hair.
I'd know and then i wondered
why i was doing all this stuff
but a major change in careers from
someone who was climbing the corporate
and similar government later
and having to give up on that path
actually started from nothing.
Being a free consultant
to the whole village
and it was many needs from filling out
forms to getting homeowners grants to
dealing with councils and so on.
And those but the benefits of
that is to give you an example one i've
started to go overseas consultancy work in
and i've been invited to seychelles botswana
india working a sensually with communities
which have the same legal structures
we have multiple occupancy is all
and some cases of course the government
department to do with structures so.
Changing a a lot of thought into realities
where i know exporting the very
solar systems we developed
here out of poverty.
This whole place is to first
sold our village in australia.
It was built not by government
brains. It was built.
By poverty people couldn't
afford anything else.
And now we're exporting that knowledge
and i see it as a as a
major growth industry.
So i could say at the end of 10 years
professionally as well as emotionally i've
gained a lot. I don't think i can recommend
a therapy i really believe that.
It's it has a deficit as well
but certainly made me healthier
and stronger than i would
have been in the city. And.
In terms of family life
couldn't have been better
but i gotta tell you there's a lot of
difference between living in a flat with the
neighbors yelling on saturday
nights and ambulances going by
and sounds to them everywhere and sitting
in your own god given nature reserve
and nothing but kookaburras and
wallabies going around and.
And you're a thing of course
nurturing friendships and in
that ten years before it
came to bill and cliff.
I didn't make one strong friends i had
acquaintances. I exchanged ideas.
I never lost my heart over anybody living
here for 10 years are developed beautiful
friendships of a level. I don't
think was possible really.
And so that has been a whole.
Really nice benefit if you i think you
know what a community means you know the
person that it's a silence quiet person
that speaks only seldom you know
once you can buy a lie on it.
I want to you can go into a oh it's a
wonderful feeling to rest we have a feeling
of belonging to a village.
I think one of the recent well not
absolutely recent but only two
or three years duration members said
to me one day said the most beautiful
thing in my life.
Is being allowed to be here and to
take in the growth of the city.
I know it is great and
i think that's been.
Only the reward for you to see
it happen as an economist
that almost put in the quaids into it
because there is a direct relationship
between work.
Non paid for which is absurd in in
society unless you're a volunteer
worker here at your whole economies
based on that unpaid work
and the payment for that
is in emotional wealth
and which is used because you don't do it
for yourself you do it for the community
and somehow it goes back to you.
And it flows around and it's something
that conventional economists of the
rationalist kind do not recognize.
You're doing this and
somebody else is doing that.
There is always looks like it's
a it's a movement of of reality
that in conventional economics is not
being measured it always has to be judy p
and out putin growth and so on. So what
we're talking about a different thing.
It's all about people
and they're talking about recycling
some shitty economic system
and we're talking about recycling people.
I give you a key example of what just
how how sound the new economics is a
definition of wealth.
Now you go to any conventional
economist any government economist
and wealth will be defined as
assets and income and self wrong.
Totally completely wrong. It only defines
have to energy. There are single time.
Now if i can make $100 a day in one second
and have the rest of the day
to listen to the summer birds.
I must by definition be wealthier than the
guy who does the same hundred dollars
and say twenty four hours.
So time is a real essence of of of
of of wealth in this economy here.
And of course you can i do it in our
salacious we are part of a system.
But here we recognize those
hidden parts of the system
and want to things we've lost over the years
right throughout the world is we have
given are.
Our neighborhood sense our sense of
community progressively over to higher
and higher authorities
first from the church
and psychiatrist to state government
federal government united nations
and ends of death and nothing wrong with
that cause we need strong
central decision making.
Obviously but we shouldn't
lose that sense of community
and that's how you clench your trees but
telling your kids if you plant that tree.
We look up to you you'll be a good
boy you know and he does it for free
and you get an emotional
charge and love out of it
and i found the same thing here using
years of getting myself in a canonic side
into deeper and deeper financial
trouble but in to be economic stress
and live like a king and
that it. Yes definitely.
Stent of living for this quality of life.
We have to move away from
originally defined set
that can see people in so-called third
world countries being defined as being on
the bottom of the poverty line yet they've
got a house the got an orchard to got
clean. They've got a wonderful.
Into a relationship but they
don't have the seedy players.
Therefore they're poor
or they don't have a wage packet because
they work in the field definite poor it's
a nonsense. If i would be a radical
revolutionary but sometimes i wish i was.
I would i would really i would transform
the whole the whole nonsense of economics.
I would rip the guts out of
economics teaching at universities
and i would actually make income
that you know london school of economics
is done more to create the problems the
world suffering from now
than any other institution.
John i went to the holland school of
economics which is just like the longest
around a top school and my school president
who was now seven years old from
that time and we write regularly.
We discussed he sings how our.
And tyre profession has sold out to the
dollar how greed is the operative word of
the entire system.
I mean this is to man who educated
30 years of of european leadership
in business messages saying the system
doesn't work we all know it isn't work.
So what we could have to do is we're going
to have to empower the lifestyle i would
like to see the amp arm and
falling to do a firing.
I'd like the people to wake up at
night and a tape of the morning
and ask them what would you like to do
they take like to plant a tree allowed to
grow my own fruit. You know not a dense
in there saying i wanted new c.d.
Players you know you don't
need us where we want to slide
society generally all across
the face of the earth.
I feel is on a very slippery
slide in the hurtling down
or you know other levers like a horse ride
you've lost the reins your feet are out
of the stirrups you
galloping headlong down.
I think
when we get to the bottom of whatever
this steep slope athens to be i
think places like selim cliffs will be there
for the reconstruction. It would seem.
We are going from strength to strength
as to system as having a haven't heard a
turret it seems
that way because we made this particular
place may not survive because it could if
that crunch comes this could be just over
iran. You know we could all be dead.
You know there knows that it's places
like this that will survive where.
The soil has been chewed
and food will grow.
It's not easy to grow food in here
without chemicals and how hard work.
How can it be easy when you do land as
been ruined. Yet when you teach your kids.
No indigenous language.
You don't tempt me into the
indigenous knowledge of plant life.
The take land is a likely change you know
you're not you're not taking your kids
out to naturally show them how to plant
food i mean this should be standard theme
in the curriculum sure they should
either they should absolutely.
Without
that you're not going to you know i remember
talking to old english guy here today.
Steven lisa came here was all he was
guys my age and a jazz fan you know
and we were brought up within probably
so you miles of each other was we had.
However how much more do you want and.
I'm happy i want to say one thing i have
a chance you might say it while you're
thinking of it you know when i hear john
talking about the system collapsing
and it's a reality in our minds
that it could happen certainly
do the indicators under a good.
I sometimes wish that. We'd have more
government cooperation that are good really.
I'd like to work for a government some
time to really work to to actually.
Do these things on a large scale i mean you
can spend 10 years of your life proving
something that everybody knows
what you did to get healthier
when you plant your own garden. You can
get a happier if you have good friends.
That's now that's not to take
this incredible discovery.
Into canberra and that is actually saying
that. Let's do it. Nifty let's do it.
Get away nifty let's take
these people and that's
and let's give them something you can
do is heaps of land which is misused
that can be. Anybody
that can be broadly bottom in your book in
your book he was to say something to yes
what you would have to waste on the
drag a bunch of flies around with him.
If you're going to ask you a question.
Reversed so we can say when we think that.
What strikes you as the main thing
you're outside you can see thunderbird
and we can hear about a billion.
Things and we go. You
know in the center of.
God this is happening and the difference.
Is that. I would say oh no no no no.
Working you know and way and people here.
Yeah it was probably you know yet
until it is very complicated.
It's the father of us all on the
moderators all assets i thought of all.
Dhammananda boaties they're really nice.
You know they're really nice but
it is that the religious trip.
You know you couldn't do
that bodie trip with a hundred fifteen
people like we did here we had a guy.
In our living body farm after 10 years
living here didn't get anything for his
house because he belongs to the
commune and effort can start again.
It's very difficult to do that. It's an
unrealistic model as a monastery right.
Yes or a religious retreat. Right. And
there we need those places and we do.
But as a model for the massive
resettlement that's got to take place.
It doesn't work. I think. Some of them.
Because of the structure
because we can't get around
that there's no trial no
we are not tribal people.
And we cannot be no matter how much we
would all like to be and we are not.
That's why we call our meeting our residents
meeting time to mull cause there's a
tribal me as you say we understand.
That tribalism is for tribal people
and even they are having trouble
living tribally nowadays.
So this is there are going to be others.
There are going to be others that will
come along which will be different.
I see it happening in the suburbs i
really do not see what would stop
well-directed government programs
into the suburbs into the small towns
that in essence are taking unemployed
people and supporting modest
and certain pensions like that and
make them contribute to society.
I really believe after 10 years of living
here in what some people describe as a
social security heaven.
I find so security system
undermining more than it does good.
I'm not saying you can just
change it and take it away.
That is not another thing i'm saying you
should direct it in a more meaningful way
more than saying to mr. a here's your
money do as you please you are free
individual that is your bread.
You can drink it you can gamble it you can
do what you want to that's for you to
live on what it misses again to
a part of the of the equation
that money must flow back into society and
therefore i think it should come tied.
If you live in a community your brief the
same area walk on the sidewalks you you
get the protection
and if any is of a deaf we should contribute
to it you know those little schemes.
There are some around where zoe lived in
red hill in brisbane opposite there was
six hours and they were
owned by a co-operative
and then you got it for a
very small amount of money
but you didn't you never owned it.
Like if you left that was so later.
I mean that it is rent.
And you know behind
that they've got a permaculture
garden a massive permaculture garden
and went right down the back of the whole
of the six houses there are virtually
food free you know you know a piece of it.
It can be done as can be done
but i believe what is required.
Now is a government takes a monument to
manchester step and the price seedy e.p.
Which is commune develop
an employment problem.
To the dole to the dole not
as an exclusive measure.
Now as a new measure
that you are allowed to settle a bit of
land where you don't get away the rattly
your residents get it and that has a
management structure like we've got here
and it says ok. You get your money
but you are 40 hours a week
doing office work to do in
that you create employment on the
spot to the money is there already.
It's a nonsense to ask someone here saying
go look for a job because right no job
and 500 miles. Even if you try
and if you did there would be five thousand
people the fun of it will be so what
you should do is saying as john said earlier
the system doesn't recognise the real
work. Therefore that the
money flow into the village.
Therefore let the village to employ
people as artists as guests people a spot
hollers or whatever you have
and then you have a locally based economy
same money same exercise city picos 20
per cent more than the door cost
it's a very wise investment.
It would change the landscape of
australia overnight in terms of people's
perception of how to take on the future.
I think the biggest problem i
have today is that i don't see
that sense to deserve a sense
we haven't this discussion.
I don't see that reflected
on a national level.
No i don't see it as being
environmental matters.
Just being used as a bloody
football you know and they grab it.
If they think it's a few votes in a knock
down if they think these few votes
that way you know.
However we're rapidly coming to the stage
where something is going to have to be
done. When we can no longer walk outside
the front door in daylight hours.
People start to get worried.
You know i don't think people don't really
want to be troubling dates you know
we're going to have to be.
No our bloody reflective suit you know
sometimes i wonder i mean we're no living in
a day
and age where you are being peddled you
the shielding clothing it's slip on a hat
put on 15 plus and you go outside
and then you're saying well the air
pollution problem is not really
that bad just yet. We had a
factor of three point two.
All at what point do we say enough.
Well look it's even crazier a place like
this which was a model in an area which
acts like a model
and one of the many areas around the world
is in fact being discriminated to the
point it has a hard time sustaining itself
we still have state government in a fact.
While undermining a sensual parts of our
local economy because it doesn't recognise
it just yet. I mean at
this day and age is crazy.
As one of them. You know renewable
energy is one ever met.
It would also go with waste
disposal toxic algae.
It goes with state systems
dispersion of grants
and so on. I found over the
years that government.
We always assume too much
brains in the government.
You know the government is a system
and the flow of money like an abc.
And it's coming back in
for the tide of taxation.
We've got several hundred you know a
hundred billion is going into the treasury
covers and then.
In tax reimbursement comes out again
and goes back and forth in government
and people and that is a very morally
process very slow to change.
So you'll find
that there is established ways of getting
money into the community we pay our
farmers at sea as our role for research.
We support our wool industry we want to put
some money into the sugar industry want
to support our doll dependents.
We want to get people's.
Legal things through our money goes back
and forth as our souls says
this whole change society.
Now what has have to happen is
we're going to have to take this.
Abnd flow of of money and
redirect it completely.
We're going to have to get a lot
of to things that are negative
and put into things sort of positive
and it's a very simple process it
just means not put into petrol
and a come of the companies first
and allow one farmer to go broke for a
million bucks to the bank on a bit of land
that he's poisoning into soul goes into
melbourne into the air you know we have to
get a thousand people
working with their hands.
And there are still people in government
saying. You can get away with that.
Yes of course you want to do it because
they don't know if you put a barrier there
saying that lance going to cost you
fifty thousand bucks. You know.
It is going back to the land that's what
all it was all about the 21st century to
me it's going to be marshall
mcluhan's global village
and you cannot live on the
land with a fax machine
and you can work for solomon brothers in
new york you don't have to live in a city
anymore. You know and therefore we can
get away from dichotomy between the city
and the rural land and we actually
can saying people are merging in
and become the caretakers of society
where we believe that the third wave
that toffler wrote about is actually
it started you know industrialisation
is dead it just going to take a while
for it to wake up to that fact
and lay down and get buried.
But industrialization is finished
and the new tribal the
new village is there
and the air space.
It's how many people got we've all got
telephones you know a couple of years ago
before we got our strata title we couldn't
afford telephones they were it eighteen
hundred dollars to put
one all in the animal.
We cities we've got the strata $400
and it was ridiculous isn't it.
We've got we've got a system of
government now that allows. Yes.
To get money from the taxpayer.
To drive a car built in
japan with oil harvested
in saudi arabia to buy vegetables
grown even switcher in thailand
and we were wondering why report it. We're
poor because we don't make our own cups.
We all make our own shirts we
don't we don't grow our own food.
And yes insta me the
answers are here it's just
that this is only a microcosm this now
has to be translated whole value here
when you go back to lismore as you just
get down off the hill part onto the flats
down there. Those flats in the
thirties used to provide sydney
and melbourne with onions and christ knows
what else. Tomatoes here and beans.
There's nothing there now but cloven hoof.
Down trodden bloody addicts
that you look at is an
obscenity those still strip.
Desperately needed
and we need if we're going to repair the
ozone by using the oxygen then it should
be against the world law for anybody
else to cut down a solitary bloody tree
and less if a pine tree slash intrigue
because the only thing trees don't do is
use. And the real obscenity is
not even the moron who cuts down
that tree on the on the slope.
Because you want to get more grass here is
cow the real obscenity is debt are whole
system pays for that nonsense and
actually obstruct the opposite.
Yes because the power has been
flowing into exactly that group
and so you're getting a situation where
literally your assets are being stripped
day and out on taxpayers money.
Still today. Well a tree.
Today you know to go
and buy a tree today of the forestry
plus about 25 bucks is a tree is.
Growing for something like 70 bloody years
as true value should be ran about three
or four hundred bucks.
John if i would be in charge of the
prime minister's department one day.
I would do the following.
I would say this land is worth so much after
you rip the trees out the arrow decile
after 30 years.
It's worth that much look at
that much to rehabilitate
and therefore this is your
taxation base just like in china.
They'll say you had your second cut your
actually go down to living standards.
So it's not fair to allow a man to
sell a cow for three fauna bucks
when in fact the taxpayer take years
and most rehabilitate that lance.
Because he didn't own that soil. He just
and this is very important an ownership.
All you own is the right to caltech and
encumbered a bit of land during your life.
Right.
And if you don't have some some clothes
you give it you can't sell be it will be
some other thing but you don't
own the land you don't own soil
that is owned by the
government all the minerals
and their own where the government
aerodrome but the government.
The only had the right to use
and therefore conventional economics betrays
the future generation because it says
rip rip rip rip rip rip pretty mount pocket
and off i go to england or whatever.
I was amazed when roz
kelly snatched back this.
Training package for primary school.
That said it told the truth then our
current disses are destroying the year.
And the farming lobby is so
bloody strong in this country
that the thing was ready to go out to
the schools and they got it stopped.
I find that scandalous they don't
want the truth to be known
but i think most young children
today. Know what's going on.
I think the primary school teachers are
doing a tremendous job with regards to the
enviro meant problems. I don't know
whether that's having any effect.
It's on the way kids
behave with litter and all
that because i don't really observe it.
I have kids around here are
generally pretty good.
Because if any adult sees a child drop
a piece of litter they do say that up.
To peter thank you very much indeed.
Thanks and would you like cup of tea.